you know the saying in news if it bleeds
it leads and when it comes to the
elections if it's a bigot we can dig it
the news media's coverage of elections
has always been a bit of a dog and pony
show like when bill clinton became black
or walking on stage with a challenge or
when that Teletubby got caught in a bear
trap it was just the wrong octave for
this time around the media's obsession
with election tainment has reached UFC
levels
look at that face I just ate a baby bird
it's in my mouth right now it's no big
secret that he who must not be named for
fear of unintended promotion has
exploited the news media's thirst for
entertainment by providing nothing but
that the media has given him two billion
dollars in free advertising more than
all other Republican contenders combined
covering him started off almost as a
joke and then it quickly became a
terrifying accident you couldn't avert
your eyes from like watching a
neighborhood kid tie a gerbil to a
bottle rocket you should probably stop
it but look how high it's going instead
of reporting on you know merits needed
to be President the media loves the
horse race in 2012 sixty-four percent of
Republican primary news coverage was
devoted to strategy polls and
fundraising that was almost six times
more coverage than on what stubborn
policy and this time around the
obsession with the horse race only seems
to have gotten worse burning at
forty-nine percent Ted Cruz eighteen
percent Kasich nine Christie eight Bush
six can someone please just tell me who
will stop the Gulf Coast from
disappearing like our tax into the swamp
of sadness
fight against the sadness Tampa even the
New York Times admitted that in a
two-week period three-fourths of its
political stories were about the horse
race and you know what calling in a
horse race is being pretty generous it's
more like a dog park of untrained
Chihuahuas who barked at shadows and
shit everywhere meanwhile who's been
hearing about these issues the one
candidate who is talking about campaign
finance has to have a mother fucking
bird land on his podium to get any
mainstream love none of this seems to
make sense that is unless you're the
media let's remember what most major
news outlets are about selling ads they
want to advertise to the one-percent not
snitch on them during the September GOP
debate CNN was able to charge 40 times
more than normal for a 30-second
commercial then there's journalistic
objectivity which the mainstream media
says they practice the same way Catholic
priests say they practice celibacy both
are dangerously unattainable I saw
spotlight so if our news coverage of
Elections continues to be a blind quest
for ratings and perceived objectivity
what will elections in the future be
like
welcome back to our post debate coverage
i'm here with candidate Ken K Cruz also
known as triple K who's just finished
pummeling his opponents bristol the
pistol Palin and New York Senator Gary
Goodman I just want to thank all the
non-muslim gods for giving me the
strength to beat the shit out of my
opponents with a poll just like I'm
beating them in the polls okay the
American people love my tax plan which
could / 100 trillion dollars from the
deficit grill iam is that even a number
will fact check that later triple K
according to a new CBS snapchat poll you
defeated bristol in the debate by a full
five bald eagles which will remind our
viewers is how we started measuring
winning under President Trump
and joining me now is bristol the pistol
palin tough loss out there bristol it's
all good cuz triple k is gonna get
triple cook arraigned on supa bruised a
now bristol senator Gary Goodman did
have you on the ropes there when he
asked you what you would do with a
nuclear New Zealand and then you said
and quite brilliantly I might add that
you would quote go nuclear on his ass
where do you come up with this stuff
he's worried about me with a finger on
the button well oh wow not one word
about policy but we're having fun
finally let's chat with Senator Gary
Goodman who's struggled throughout this
entire debate and probably from the
looks of it his entire life senator
Goodman what would you have done
differently well I want to talk about
the issues okay citizens united I will
overturn it I think corporations are not
people even the ones that kind of look
like people are actually androids with
super computer brains and well I'd like
to talk about the issues if I could have
a second to talk about Social Security
Wang please oh there's been a wang
challenge ladies and gentlemen and
according to election rules in 20-40
both candidates must compare wang sizes
on live television because that's how
elections work these days well that
wraps up our post debate coverage
remember folks you don't have to take
time off your 5th job and swim through
glacier melt to get to the ballot boxes
just text your choice to vote slam 2040
and our androids will tabulate the
results and may the most entertaining
asshole win
you